[Music]
White Castle the restaurant
what restaurant White Castle is we don't
have any for you right now I'm just met
people like give me White Castle is
offering 10 to let dinner service for
Valentine's Day tomorrow yeah candlelit
dinner it's the perfect way to tell your
partner I'm hungry and I don't love you
that much I couldn't believe this it's
been projected that Americans will spend
over 13 billion dollars this Valentine's
Day yeah and guys who forget Valentine's
Day will spend over 100 billion dollars
there's no getting out of that hole
there's no getting out of there right
that's why there's a 5-gallon bucket of
chili in my car right now
no way I'm falling to that that's what
you have planned for your wife it's in
the Toronto heart-shaped tub nice
sit in it not anything in a heart-shaped
tub where it's sundown today that's
fishing I put it in a hurt chef tub you
all watch the Grammys last night that
was a yeah last night Adele won six
Grammy yeah yeah the the winds made
Adele so happy she now has nothing left
to sing about what is she gonna sing
about now I don't like this meal as much
as I thought I would right I have to
figure out way it's just been my Mon
yeah Katy Perry showed up at the Grammys
last night with blue hair see Katy Perry
with blue hair yeah the hair was so
striking Katy had to keep yelling at
everyone Hey my breasts are down here
hello
No
no reason there was no reason for any of
that and I apologize last night Nicki
Minaj showed up at the Grammys red
carpet with someone dressed as the Pope
yeah either that or the Pope has a lot
of explaining to do why can't he have a
good time
you see this the Beach Boys reunited at
the Grammys last night yeah
Beach Boys they're headed out on tour
for their I guess it's their 50th
anniversary oh really yeah
yeah and now when they sing about
surfing they mean surfing the internet
for discounted prostate medicine
in a new interview samuel l.jackson said
the only reason he voted for President
Obama in 2008 is because he's black yeah
which explains President Obama's new
2012 campaign slogan hey everybody I'm
still black you like it in no way
it doesn't really work when I do that
down still black
said the whitest person ever a new
report this is fascinating shows that
Osama bin Laden didn't want his kids to
follow in his footsteps yeah
which explains why Jeremy bin Laden is
in his third year of dental school we
liked it at rehearsal to picture Jeremy
don't applaud my process
oh hi kid don't like it's good to give
up a rehearsal
Jeremy been loitering army but his name
people saying like yeah it's a familiar
last name and I go dude wrong guy yeah
no that's Jeremy bin liya my family
swiss yeah
we're there with a Swiss bin Laden yeah
yeah yeah the Swiss name in Texas this
week I couldn't believe this what's that
say you're from Texas
I hope so if you're gonna do that in the
middle of a show just general Texas in
Texas this week a woman walked away from
a car crash uninjured because her 38
triple K breasts acted as airbags we
believe that yeah Divya the accident was
caused when the other driver got
distracted by a woman
[Applause]
you